en un an vous faites l'année d'une vie
d'un mec des fois vous acheter des
maisons à 6 millions dont des voitures à
200000 euros
bah si mais j'en connais avait vu
millions d'euros 8,6 millions dont 200
mille euros il ya des gens des animaux
mais je parle de peut-être plusieurs
maisons des voitures à 200000 euros ça
existe oui c'est oui les mecs la révolte
du ghetto urbain le faire sauf que tu as
eu la chance de le faire alors quand ça
va ça va mal le problème c'est ce que je
pense moi c'est que mon avis les gens
pensent que ces éternels moi j'ai pas
arrêté mon camion tu m'as offert une
récré ya un nom je continue à les livrer
tous les matins 5h30 lèvent tous les
mois quand je vois que j'ai gagné un peu
d'argent que j'économise at mp je veux
voir mon banquier jeu mais pour le
crédit de la maison pour baisser les
mensualités
parce que ça c'est une récré ça va
s'arrêter forcément il pense malgré tout
ça il peut vous nassar éternelle c'est
ouvert ça va s'arrêter plus vite pour
certains pour mais non je vais finir
vite fait il faut pas penser que ces
éternels et maintenant après il faut
peut-être faire une reconversion sûr que
c'est difficile d'aller faire caissier
quant à fait pascal lorot sa danse est
difficile de revendre et moi je leur
adresse mes côtés j'ai pas fait que ces
communes comme nous venons c'est bien
sûr qu'on suggère parce que moi je suis
là bas je suis éducateur j'ai eu la
chance d'être à projeter la télé dans ce
métier mais aujourd'hui moi je continue
ce métier comment atteindre parce que je
vois je suis je suis fonctionnaire a dit
j'ai pas honte de le dire mon métier je
vais continuer aujourd'hui effectivement
j'ai une vraie vision
on a eu la chance de pouvoir parler de
ce métier qui te compliquer mais cette
vision moi je vais pas cracher dessus
et aujourd hui je suis en train de me
plains tu portes un dollar tout va bien
je donne mon argent je dois gens gagnent
moins certes mais tout va bien parce que
j'entends descente aux enfers fini très
vite jean veillon descente aux enfers b
lancé aux mecs qui a été pendant pas des
usines pendant votre de choses chez
harper dans ce régime a toujours des
mecs qui vont au boulot pendant 20 ans
miller au lendemain on lui dit tu es
licenciés ta boîte elle ferme elle part
en turquie il faut qu'ils rentrent le
matin le soir 9 ans et trois gosses dire
papa l ape et l'ossétie la découverte de
500 balles
magique non vraiment je suis d'accord et
il soulève un problème raymond c'est que
les mecs qui ont connu la célébrité
c'est qu'ils veulent pas faire d'autres
métiers oui y'a des mecs qui veulent pas
se remettre en question et ils ont honte
d'aller faire des métiers d'un normand
et des métiers ou dans lesquels ils sont
pas dans la lumière ça sera gérable
aussi mais un tuner une actrice connue
quand même se retrouve chez darty toute
la journée on va même pas lui parler des
instruments va lui dire [ __ ] mais vous
jouez plus que ce que vous faites là
c'est un cas unique au format daunay qui
a bossé avec jean luc azoulay
fonctionner lorsque tous les prix voilà
qui était pas d'enquêté un toubib street
extrêmement connu et puis un jour ils
étaient 13 dans un club parisien un club
de sport et il a vu des dd mc solaar des
mecs connu que du roi toi aussi tu
t'entraînes ici ça vous hyper cher c'est
des salles à 4 5 me de balle par an il a
répondu ben non pardon je suis coach et
c'était très dur pour lui voilà tout
d'un coup il redevient coach était à
mille euros par mois et effectivement
c'est très difficile de changer de
métier parce qu'en pu saisir un petit
peu rondes parce que c'est sur leur
visage est marqué l'échec c'est pas ça
le plus dur c'est les réseaux sociaux en
fait les gens autour de moi moi j'ai des
gens qui voient là qui me soutiennent
aujourd'hui mais le plus dur c'est les
gens sur les réseaux ils se sont
acharnés sur moi depuis qu'on a appris
ça moi j'ai juste dit la vérité et je me
dis mais en fait on peut rien dire soit
je m'en effectivement à mon contrat
effectivement sur ces 8 s'est arrêté je
sais pas si on renégocie pour pour les
prochaines fêtes - change pas inquiète
parce que j'ai pas pour être sérieux
parce que c'est compliqué effectivement
de quand on le vit en tout cas tant
qu'on ne vit pas on sait pas de combat
mais quand on est donc comme vous comme
benjamin a le plus dur c'est de se dire
mais qu'est ce qu'on va faire maintenant
bon moi j'ai la chance de pouvoir faire
autre chose mais mais c'est compliqué de
ne plus être dans la lumière
effectivement c'est ça qui est dur
puisqu'il a pu voir c'est les gens qui
vous allume pour rien gratuitement
moi je les commentaires négatifs j'en ai
vu ce d'état mais j'en tiens pas compte
parce que ça va me détruire et j'ai pas
envie de les reconnaître détruits par
des gens qui ne connaissent pas je vous
tourner vers valérie valérie on va pas
se mentir
tu as connu un gros creux un vrai dans
ta carrière est ce que toi un moment tu
as été une très grosse difficulté parce
que détecté sur tf1 était sur rtl
remontent avaient des salaires énormes
toi tu étais tu avais mis de côté parce
que tu as eue moi j'aimerais moi je me
suis toujours dit que c'était un métier
et que donc il la célébrité c'était une
chose est mon métier sans été une autre
et donc j'ai été j'ai été une petite
mère de famille
j'ai fait attention j'ai géré mon petit
budget saluons tout raté même temps j'ai
eu trois ans compliqué croisons tu
travaillais pas du tout venant si je
travaillais mais du coup justement j'ai
pris mon métier différemment
je me suis dit qu'il fallait que j'aie
un autre point de vue est que la télé
c'était une partie de ce métier là donc
j'ai écrit des livres je suis allé au
théâtre et puis sur venu ici en vous
présentant justement une pièce de
théâtre et c'est comme ça que je suis
revenue entre guillemets dans une autre
dans là dedans une lumière qui était
différente de celle que j'avais accepté
pendant trois ans faut aussi un moment
se dire se remettre en cause de dire on
va peut-être que cette vie là elle est
finie et quel métier je peux faire un
majeur métier de journaliste comment je
peux l'exercer balaj mais j'avais trouvé
des solutions a été la presse écrit
enfin la littérature et le théâtre
un moment où étiez vous étiez en bad
vraiment vous êtes bien moment j'arrive
vraiment revanche là où c'est compliqué
c'est que même si vous vivez plutôt bien
en disant je prend le parti de dire que
c'est une partie de ma vie et c'est
terminé tout le monde vous ramène vous
allez faire vos courses où vous prenez
un le métro on peut peu importe ce que
vous faites
on vous dit mais on vous voit plus la
télé qu'est-ce que vous devenez comme si
vous étiez disparus et quelque part on
vous renvoie un échec moi je fais
tourner sur ces 8 mais il ya quand même
un mec je vous jure que c'est vrai mais
un mec
avant-hier il m'a dit mais qu'est ce tu
deviens toi on a il a vu tout et on lui
avait arrêté ses 8 oui vous vous
rappelez quand j'étais viré tf1 même ça
reste un des plus beaux jours
on n'avait plus le sport nous rejoigne
et bernard montiel il c'était une grande
star de tf1 toujours une star d'ailleurs
mais plus de neuf ans et c'est vrai
qu'il avait balancé sur tout le monde il
est pas loin mais surtout les animateurs
étaient très joué ses lyrics t'avais dit
quoi dit noureddine ou ce que tellement
beau non si tu avais dit arthur il sait
pas ici d un palier après palier à
prendre peur derrière elle son fils est
nul ça va j'ai revu tout le monde tout
se passe bien à cette ut réconcilier
tout le monde non mais non d'accord si
nate a pris toi un moment le mec il
était tranquille à l'été ils étaient à
tf1 il faisait vidéo gag ça veut dire il
faisait 3 lancement idéale et maintenant
avoir un chien mis ses abonnés 20000
euros par mois sur coup sûr il a fallu
tableau ajoute c'est parce qu'il arrive
et il a dû prendre trop point soleil l'a
45 minutes de phase iia et prie le ciel
aux tueries des butins ça c'est de la
merde c'est vraiment
[Applaudissements]
j'ai justement quand on a une situation
aussi confortable je faisais aussi la
famille en or je faisais la une est à
bout mais il ya autre chose j'ai adoré
vidéo gag dans les textes et écrit par
laurent baffie je le rappelle à chaque
fois donc à leur chien qui pète vous le
dirai à laurent baffie mais il se trouve
ci voulait qu'au bout d'un moment je
l'avais pas courage d'arrêter comme ça
de céder ses sirènes de l'argent vous
gagner beaucoup d'argent sur seulement
ce que je voulais dire ce que quand je
suis parti de là même si c'était prévu
dans ma tête je me suis retrouvé à
devoir payer un loyer à paris la bagnole
tous âges et tous les kids et je vous
assure j'ai tous les kids et l'hymne
truies soleil à un moment quand il prend
la bonne chère y paraît après je me
rends sait mais en tout cas tout ça et
vous tu as fais toi sort maintenant je
vais te dire moi je vois la question que
tout le monde me pose je te le jure je
veux dire aux téléspectateurs
c'est bernard montiel comment il a fait
toutes ces années parce qu'on a toujours
l'impression qu'il était très frais et
qu'il avait beaucoup d'argent
il était partout comment tu as fait ce
qui est achats space un complément de sa
non mais sans rigoler nommé bernard
comment t'as fait parce que t'as pas
travaillé pendant combien de temps la
télé et ben non non juste donner vite
revenu et mc non oui oui je suis rentré
très vite à tmc reprendre mon métier de
10 et j'étais prêt à en prendre mon
métier d'huissier
non mais moi j'ai fait d'autres métiers
donc j'étais prêt à faire d'autres
choses et je n'avais pas la vie cette
justice nous a souri mais non je me suis
occupée
j'étais venu ici c'est ma formation de
droit et puis j'avais d'autres métiers
d'une boîte de comm aussi tout ça donc
je me suis démerdé avec ça il se trouve
que j'ai eu la chance comme monsieur qui
s'appelle gérald brice viret le patron
de canal plus maintenant mais à l'époque
était il venait d'arriver il a quitté la
chaîne voyage pour diriger tmc on se
connaissait pas il m'appelle écoutez je
crois que n'ai pas de job de télé à
paris venait me voir on s'est vus et
voilà ils jaillissent sympa lui même
soit pas lui
naïma ce qui m'a sauvée passe car ils
écoulent en faire du bois de la télé
mais j'avais d'autres choses c'était pas
un drame non plus ouais d'accord
éventuellement murray s'était pas tout
témoignage en soi une des grosses
différences qui fait que les gens sombre
comme ça et c'est vrai que c'est un peu
incompréhensible qu'on n'est pas un
métier c'est que quand on a un métier
dit normal on perd son job tu viens on
va chercher un autre boulot c'est
consommer en kenza farah le travail
corneau sa vie d'artiste aux périodes on
perd son job
on attend que le téléphone sonne on peut
attendre longtemps comme ça et on s'en
fout tout doucement comme ça il qu'on
recommence à ce débat parce que ça c'est
trop tard pour se débattre et on attend
ce n'est pas pareil vous tous ici ce
sera ma dernière question soir pour les
téléspectateurs doivent dans ce dossier
là donc aussi d' instigation après il ya
beaucoup de choses qui arrivent enfin
voilà benjamin voilà mais vous tous vous
dit si ça s'arrête demain tous assis
voilà demain on décide d'arrêter
qu'est ce que vous allez faire ce que
vous allez continuer dans le métier ou
est ce que vous dites moi je vais faire
autre chose je vais arrêter
beinheim non mais moi j'ai changé
puisque ça m'est arrivé donc j'ai déjà
songé je m'excuse poids bah je vais
continuer à écrire des livres enfin
voila c'est bon vous êtes pas de plan b
1 barber shop
j'ai cherché sur google un métier on
galbi on fout rien n'y a pas d'autre mot
de la fin il a raison